hiya Johnny hi Craig no I didn't just
buy these clothes for this video I don't
know what you're talking about does you
look amazing this is what I'm used to
seeing all the way around the office can
you pass me the scissors yeah absolutely
sorry I just I've had this on my clothes
for years yeah years I've had it on
always having to remind you to take the
tags off of clothes that you've had for
years and years it's a habit but this is
what I always wear hey speaking of oh
clothes what citizens of the reject
Nation we are finally gonna watch the
Barbie movie the movie everyone else has
seen but we had our Comic-Con panel as
time went on we're like I guess we're
not watching this in the theaters I
think we're just gonna react to it I'm
streaming and here we are I'm so excited
to see this really quick I want to share
this it's been our background for a
while my sister got me this uh Ken
Barbie doll Ryan Gosling version it was
my birthday recently so happy birthday
to amwa I'm so excited to see this I
have had this muted on all social media
for the longest time the only slither of
a spoiler that I got was that there's an
hen song in here but I haven't heard a
single second of it not be nothing I am
ready for this so please go ahead leave
a like on this video that'd be very much
appreciated I'm not used to armrest ah
subscribe click the notification Bell so
you get notified when our next reaction
is up here in the channel because we're
covering so much right now and also
thank you to prepper for helping us out
down these highlights lastly as always
massive thank you to all who have joined
our patreon page becoming super sexy
rejects over there you can catch the
full-length Reaction watch along re-sync
up with your own copy of Barbie we cover
several things exclusive over there with
reaction highlights and watch along as
included thank you again to all joined
let's finally see with all the hype is
about cannot wait
[Music]
are we starting off with these since the
beginning of time we are
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been
yes I love that this is actually part of
it the girls who played with them could
only ever play it being mother
wow
[Music]
gorgeous
she's an Amazon
other dolls mattered I'm very happy they
committed to this I was afraid it was
just gonna be a teaser bit
create transition Bobby changed every
swim in a Barbie and Barbie is all of
these women diversity what about Tori
she has her own money her own house her
own career because Barbie can be
anything these are all Easter eggs and
references to real life jobs all
problems are feminism
[Music]
thank you
well done Babs and here is one of those
Barbies now living her best day every
day
now she's just one of those Barbies
[Music]
it's a fun song is this completely
unproblematic lizzo
come on we got important things to do
it's her
even garbage day is glamorous in Barbie
land goes with everything beautiful from
man this production design is gorgeous
the shot the Tarantino shot
you just look so good on us
love it I like the symmetry of these
shots a lot yeah very Wes Anderson like
man this set is insane I just want to
examine every detail
they're so good at personifying like the
imaginary play Vibe like the right
amount of things are real and fake yeah
[Music]
great choreography it's nice to get a
song too that is like a theme song of
the main character
pink just looks get your vitamin C
Barbie or your vitamin A and D it's
doing a good job of capturing the appeal
of an artifice life nobody bothers to
walk from down the stairs and out the
door Etc you just pick them up and put
them where you want them to go Marilyn
[Music]
hi Barbie
hi Skipper Skipper yes her sister she
was discontinued by Mattel because a
pregnant doll is just too weird oh guess
so little pregnant girls deserve to see
themselves in a toy as well
everybody turn to the party The Pink
House you can ask me any question you
want so how come you're so amazing
female friendship I have no difficulty
holding both logic and feeling at the
same time
[Laughter]
I can tell it's going to be very much a
ride
hey awesome
Bobby has a great day every day but Ben
only has a great day yes if Barbie looks
at him oh ken hi Barbie
hi Ken hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
get out of here
oh hi Alan there are no multiples of
Alan he's just Alan he's just Alan we
all are check me out
[Music]
oh what are you gonna do buddy catch
that wave boy
again oh
[Music]
kid physics are the best oh looks like
this beach was a little too much Beach
for you Ken what's Beach off anyone who
wants to beat him up has to beat me off
first I will beat both of you up you can
beat each other off let's go
jeez Ken is extremely codependent no
he's so cool stay with me Barbie
great not even broken you'll be fine oh
jeffer's not even my job I know and it
is not lifeguard which is a common
misconception
I didn't know that can I come to your
house tonight sure sure I don't have
anything they planned just a giant
blowout party with all the Barbies and
planned choreography oh my goodness
God this must have been fun to shoot
[Music]
God got the star power in this movie
oh is this um is this like Some Like It
Hot is this a Marilyn Monroe like
tribute I bet they're gonna be a lot of
like classic movie tribute shots and
sequences
looking good Barbie thanks guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
such faces he makes
what's up cats
wow you can move yeah
[Applause]
perfectly perfect and you look so
beautiful Barbie thanks Barbie I feel so
beautiful so supportive Best Day Ever
and so is yesterday and so is tomorrow
and always will be
[Applause]
but life is not perfect
whoa what a question
I'm just dying to dance those intrusive
thoughts will get you a way to cover it
up existential dread is always creeping
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're girlfriend boyfriend she
did what
I'm actually not sure
hurry up the president's here I am
you're welcome giant brush
I can't I gotta go
[Music]
saddy plays him keep telling yourself
that button Barbies I'm
thinking about death anymore
that's how I go to sleep wow so it's
also gonna be a story about acceptance
and realizing what lies beyond your
bubble
now wake up in my own world and wait for
my home girl
[Laughter]
Fleet Pariah people are going to start
noticing that you're not being Peppy
I love that gag so much
I love how it's
how it's her mind creating all this yeah
it's all just the perception
oh no oh girl you okay
Come on Barbie let's run towards the
water okay
what happens when we get there oh
what just happened she's a paraplegic
now
[Applause]
fake vomit
I know I'm stereotypical Barbie and
therefore don't form conjectures
concerning the causality of adjacent
unfolding events but something jeez
so they're five times fast you're
malfunctioning what you're gonna have to
visit weird Barbie I have never had to
visit weird Barbie that's because you've
never malfunctioned who is weird Barbie
beautiful Barbie of all but then someone
played with her too hard in the real
world
Sid
oh no okay I'm here to understand this
world uh
oh my gosh she's like Sid
damn what great sets oh I would never
wear heels
picking them on themes of not conforming
to how your societal Norms of how you
should be yeah but being true to who you
who you really are hey
what's cooking good looking was that
Kate McKinnon
I think so
to come see you about my feet
there um
[Laughter]
you've opened a portal and now there is
a rift in the Continuum that is the
membrane between Barbie land and the
real world oh no baby girl you gotta go
fix it you're gonna keep going funny
look at your upper thigh gotta go fix it
into the Barbie version cellular that's
gonna spread everywhere and then you're
gonna start getting sad and mushy and
complicated no
I know you have to go to the real world
and you have to find the girl who's
playing with you oh there's the girl and
the doll and never the twain shall cross
interesting oh wow why would she be sad
we fixed everything so that all women in
the real world can be happy and Powerful
yes
I can't have I've only ever wanted for
everything to stay exactly as it is well
the two of you are becoming inextricably
intertwined what interesting she's
Tethered to the human like that is her
Barbie like the only person in her life
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the
universe the first one the high heel
damn it Neo you have to want to know
okay do it again I'm not Adventure
Barbie I'm stereotypical Barbie I'm like
the Barbie you think of when someone
says think of a Barbie
it worked I did that is why she was cast
here I just gave you a choice so you
could feel some sense of control so
there is no option one
giving you a choice so you could feel
some sense of control wow
holy crap that's a base
oh manipulating a choice is crazy I'm
trying to find reason s not to leave
they're gonna miss you guys so much I
just wish someone could come with me but
you can't
now's your time what bird am I thinking
of parrot dolphin I mean no a bird
you'll get to see all the good work
we've done to fix the world you'll be
such a hero to them I'll bet every woman
will say thank you and give you a really
big hug
boiling the movie
it's like so vibrant and uplifting but
there's such a melancholic undertone
here at all too it's like a sugary pop
song with sad lyrics introspection
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hey Roger Rabbit
I can't I made a double bet with Ken you
can't make me look uncool in front of
Ken
appears to me
ouch there's so much about his
appearance
so insecure I love it did you bring your
roller blades
I literally go nowhere without them
please
okay where were you hiding those
wow what an adventure
I love a good montage
[Music]
no okay don't fly off the space
laughs
and we're here the set photos nice this
is 30 minutes away from us
I actually think in the real world no
one would bat an eye yeah
I feel kind of abilities like I don't
know the word for it but I'm conscious
but it's myself that I'm conscious of oh
I feel what could only be described as
admire
appreciate it I'm such a narcissist
[Music]
I would just like to inform you I do not
have a vagina wow whoa oh my goodness we
don't have genitals that's okay yeah I
have all the janitors I have all the
genitals one of each everything's almost
like
reversed here
I always got a little smile on his face
yeah I get a taste of power
that's what I'm talking about Barbie
well done and again
on it that's a little tiny little and
it's great I love Fringe those are fresh
strips where'd they get the money hey
man
she looks even better than real clothes
big pack in jail who is playing with me
what am I supposed to do
by myself really where
it reminds me of Michael Scott
it's just so like unbelievably needy
he's got Michael Scott and some of that
Nicholas Cage like
wildness like subdued but
what's up man
we got a man up on this one great
workout man oh yeah you found the Ken
Den smartest at the center the center
piece of image and security yeah totally
and status you could have done New York
also but I like it but we sell dreams
and Illusions here yeah good stuff so
I'm not worried about it not now
Margaret let's Jake on this
learn my son
[Music]
welcome to the Ken triarchy this is what
being a man's all about yeah get your
creatine boy
that's what I imagine when I meditate a
little girl don't be a creep John you
know just like nice
childhood memory and she dies in a
violent yeah that's why I've been
thinking about that bones burning wreck
[Music]
okay Goodwill product placement
the mark of a good actor
training my ducts it's interesting she
steps into the real world and she's
getting a dose of the hardship of being
a woman yeah Ken's getting what it's
like when men are put on a pedestal and
behind the power they get yeah yeah when
men are the form in control yeah
[Music]
there's an array of emotions out there
and everyone is experiencing them
you're old Barbie
oh
I know it oh is she the Creator yeah
it's great at girl work
this is critical wig inventor of Barbie
okay
welcome
oh and the reality that men are
controlling Barbie yeah yeah
somewhere in a boardroom even if a woman
invented it this happened before a woman
named Skipper turned up at some family's
home in Key West asked to babysit the
kids whoa is that a reference to a
skipper movie you may never come back
I know
I love the way they're portraying the
Mattel Corporation right now
wow this feels like we're stepping into
a Black Mirror episode now oh it's her
yeah she's grown up just started drawing
these weird designs these are different
it's irrepressible thoughts of death
Barbie
full body cellulite Barbie
no one wants this reality Barbie is my
internal monologue Barbie they're in a
big corporate idea session no one is to
be admitted oh my God are we going to
get the purest Taste of capitalism where
they'd actually put these toys out
eating disorder bar really you can buy
them now and when you take a sparkle
what do you think after that
female agency
yes one comes right after the other
let's get all these Kens
oh Jesus
Warner Brothers Discovery logos in the
back geez everything has this like
Center frame yeah if this got out that
our dolls were coming to Los Angeles
from Barbie land Barbie in the real
world
that's impossible you created this
awesome anymore is Barbie land like an
alternate reality or is it like a place
where uh your imagination is yes
[Laughter]
whatever you think it is you're right
I've started to get all these weirdo
feelings like I have fear with no
specific object what do anxiety
you need to find her soon I'm just gonna
pop into the library and see if I can
find any books on trucks okay just don't
get in trouble I won't they're like
brother and sister too like they bicker
like kids
who are you I'm only your favorite woman
of all time
Barbie
hated dolls with hair I mean I played
with Barbie but it was like the last
resort I loved Barbie
no you didn't you've been making women
feel bad about themselves since you were
invented you've represent everything
wrong with her culture sexualized
capitalism unrealistic physical life no
no go for it describing something
stereotypical Barbie is
so much more than that it was the
stereotype
you destroy girls innate sense of worth
and you are killing the planet with your
glorification of rampant consumerism
and until you showed up here and
declared yourself Barbie I hadn't
thought about you in years you fascist
wow
fascist Barbie get a taste of that gen Z
oh I'm gonna stop yelling at my Barbie
dolls you know what I yeah we should all
treat our Barbies nicer
be more compassionate to them
[Music]
why man rule sir do you have the time
you respect me
sorry no do you know what time it is
why didn't Barbie tell me about
patriarchy which to my understanding is
where men and horses run everything
sure oh my I'll take a high level high
paying job with influence please okay
you'll need at least an NBA isn't being
a man enough actually right now it's
kind of the opposite you guys are
clearly not doing patriarchy very well
yeah
we're doing it well yeah we just uh hide
it better now yeah
oh you want to be a lifeguard I'm
trained to stand confidently right here
there's nobody in danger here and even
if there were I'm not trained to save
them
[Laughter]
can
still have to work hard Ken I need to
find somewhere where I can start
patriarchy fresh
oh my poor Mattel everything is
backwards here men look at me like I'm
an object girls hate me everyone thinks
I'm crazy and I keep getting arrested
I'll go back to Barbie land and I'll
tell the Ken's what I've learned oh it's
going to be beautiful oh oh my God is
Ken gonna become a villain is Ken gonna
become like a dictator
reality challenged woman she thinks
she's Barbie what did you say she thinks
she's Barbie
what are you doing that's her Barbie
[Music]
you worked there yeah just catch up
[Laughter]
you're so happy to see you would you
like some mineral one yes thank you
if you could just
get into that giant box
you know what we should probably get Ken
first you know Ken Barbie and Ken Ken
get the guy yeah the guy
Ken isn't something we're worried about
ever
could I just meet the woman in charge oh
that would be me oh you're CFO me your
c-o-o here president of the Barbie
division I'm a man with no power does
that make me a woman
[Music]
nope we have gender neutral bathrooms up
the Wazoo every single one of these men
love women
I'm the son of a mother
I'm the mother of a son
I'm I'm the nephew of a woman aunt
true facts Progressive get in the Box
you Jezebel yes jeez you filthy
oh and I've been real priesty and
flashback get in the Box damn that is
Icky
oh no oh the restrainment the twist ties
not the twist ties could I just run to
the restroom and make sure my hair is
perfect here's an underlying horror to
this film oh definitely these guys are
so creepy
I guess you really had to go to the
bathroom
yep that was a really unsettling thing
but with the box and the rest I feel
like there's a lot something much deeper
there well yeah it feels like poisoned
nice guy Femme feminism like
foreign
daring Escape Plan Barbie actually is
like a a tinge of a Sci-Fi touch to it
so I think the 2001 opening is pretty
pretty emblematic of the experience here
because it's a reflection on a reality
don't worry you're safe here
whoa what is this place it is a Black
Mirror quality
learning to drink she's just learning
how to be real world isn't what I
thought it was that happens a lot
and isn't that marvelous
Discovery is she the Creator I'm just
gonna ask that every time an older woman
shows up on screen
I think probably Ruth thank you Ruth
Ruth there you go yeah I forget what her
last name is but yeah I think the
Creator's name is Ruth we got her there
she is
a minute ago
come on come with me if you want to live
these guys are so petty
little lonely lately
be joyful was it no it wasn't the power
of imagination and then the drawings got
sad and weird and maybe because I
couldn't be like you I ended up making
you like me
I came for you
those were your memories
it's like a Westworld Flair to this
man so weird many colliding movies a
sci-fi movie it is it's a sci-fi film
hello are you two like Shining
this is weird weird commentary about
creation yeah creation play bonding and
the power of imagination as well
boring mom with a boring job and a
daughter who hates me can you blame me
for wanting to have a little fun
I gotta lose these chuckleheads when you
need somebody to project onto just as
much as to inspire you especially when
you're feeling alone and cut off from a
loved one I do like how they they wrote
Barbie to be like she's very she
has a strong vocabulary her vernacular
is very wide-ranging yeah yeah she's
intelligent yeah
whoa
Barbie
when Imaginary Land yeah because I never
get to do anything I didn't even go on
that cruise I wanted your school raffle
because I didn't have enough vacation
days and your dad's allergic to sign
what graphos
killing it killing it Ken
to it a little set
make your own choices Woman as a man I
give you permission
I urge you to do all the things I can
even though I've set it up at a skew
[Music]
it's like the Barbie world is a fantasy
idea yeah for for girls to hold on to
and it just leads to them being
depressed because it's not the reality
yeah yeah they can never get back there
I totally understand it I feel it I grew
up with it my inner little girl's
satiated by that totally get it that's
strange
oh no Ken what have you done
incoming brewsky beer
president what happened to you Ken has
introduced the male patriarchy he's
introduced the male gays
whoa have a brewsky beer my big guy is
thirsty a brewsky bear wait until you
see my dream house everything I've
bought and owned will totally inspire
you and we can change clothes again
that's the capital oh this is Turtle no
cat is a villain
oh my God Mount Rush horse there was a
minute where I thought it was run by
horses
but then I realized that horses are just
men extenders yes
compensate for whatever you need
oh my God
everything exists to expand and Elevate
the presence of men
it's beautiful this is beautiful wow
this is my dream house it is my dream
house it's mine no this is no longer
Barbie
be known as Ken's Mojo Dojo Casa house
try it
Mojo Dojo Casa house Mojo Dojo Casa
house
houses are literally flying off the
shelf the kids are clambering for them
they're still pink are boys buying it I
guess which is already a black buster
hit yes
oh this movie's brilliant yeah it's
brilliant it stopped provoking as hell
but also very accessible yeah really fun
yeah but still not leaving like no punch
bowl no stone unturned
for my long-term low commitment distance
girlfriend
I love that we just pick up the
embodiment of masculine toxicity
the ultimate Chad yes I know isn't it
great and Alan likes to help me give all
the Ken's foot massages no I don't I
don't like that we love it uh and it's
going to be just like Century City in
Los Angeles because they had it all
figured out
Century City no no no they don't have it
figured out in Century City because we
failed them no you failed me
wow out there I was somebody people
respected me just for who I am you just
wanted approval ouch
and if it weren't for these
technicalities like NBAs I could have
ruled that world but I don't need any of
those things here
I'm just a dude
I'm just a dude living in kentivity I
love that it became a villain yeah I
love that choice
I love it
and now you're making it permanent with
a special election to change the
Constitution awesome with all the
council ahead to the polls and vote to
change the Constitution to a government
for the Kens of the cans and by the cans
oh my God this is so many layers deep I
can't believe it oh my God how's that
feeling
it is not fun is it I don't recall her
ever being this cruel yeah I mean the
patriarchy has existed long before
Barbie got he's like bullying yeah Brown
beating
oh she's crying in Barbie land take your
lady Fashions with you
why did you wish me to your messed up
world using your Barbie's land was
perfect before I was perfect before
I've never wanted anything to change
that's life it's constant only thing in
life that's constant that's terrifying
yeah really understand this feeling it's
basically like being a human person all
the time
very much
okay
you know I almost feel bad
moving like he only got four joints
it's much more repulsive R rated to pray
version of this movie out there
the endless possibilities time to run
out
yes no they're doing it yes and
in time until she falls asleep they're
doing the thing I thought they were
gonna do
[Music]
Bond we interrupt this broadcast to
bring you our new radio station only
playing Ken's favorite song
this Matchbox 20.
tomorrow
[Music]
I cannot sit on one more leather couch
it's gonna break my spirit
as soon as they figure out how to build
that wall sideways and not just up no
one is going to be able to get in or out
[Laughter]
one person would care if Ellen was in
the real world in fact it's happened
before all of NSYNC Allen
all offense beautiful I'm Ken's buddy
yeah all his clothes fit me
you've been hanging out with Kung Fu bar
give me Scott Pilgrim back yeah Alan
earned the power of self-respect even if
you can't make it perfect you can
mimic anything better I'm the one who
ruined Barbie land with my stupid
drawings in the first time I'm not
stupid they're amazing you're amazing
Mom they're weird and dark and crazy
everything you pretend not to be hmm
being authentic to your true self let's
go get my dog
[Music]
the hair whip he did all that ass
kicking for none just run to the real
world yourself Alan you're in Magic
again this is sugar and I'm her daddy oh
it's and I have an earring a magic
carrier uh they're cameos no he's the
guy from the trip I know his name Rob
Ryden I'm not
an idiot anymore oh I'm not
stereotypical Barbie pretty note to the
filmmakers Margot Robbie is the wrong
person to cast if you want to make this
point
it's about the feeling
I'm brilliant
I'm not the president
no one on the Supreme Court is me
I'm not
good enough
for anything
he's such a great actress yeah it is
literally impossible to be a woman we
have to always be extraordinary but
somehow we're always doing it wrong yeah
what's up with that guys
get this together come on fix this and
you can never say you want to be thin
you have to say you want to be healthy
but also you have to be thin so you you
do understand yeah
it was a program
Chop Chop ladies you have to lead but
you can't squash other people's ideas
you're supposed to love being a mother
but don't talk about your kids all the
damn time you have to be a career woman
but also always be looking out for other
people
answer for men's bad behavior which is
insane but if you point that out you're
accused of complaining I know it bothers
me yeah should you guys please keep it
down other women because you're supposed
to be a part of The Sisterhood but
always stand out and always be grateful
woof this is really a great speech this
is bars you have to never get old never
be rude never show off never get out of
line it's too hard it's too
contradictory and nobody gives you
thank you
are you doing everything wrong but also
everything is your fault wow
a man must have written this no Obama
yo here he goes directed the movie and
if all of
them it's like they want to put women
into a box I did write a book
like I've been in a dream where I was
somehow really invested in the Zack
Snyder cut of Justice League
who's wrong with that what did this move
this River just lost
you need to say all of those things to
the other Barbies that's the key okay
here's the deal it's not just about how
they see us it's about how they see
themselves exactly distract them by
appearing helpless and Confused pens
cannot resist a damseling distress
no we cannot we can't anything to prop
ourselves up to look like a savior shop
is so hard I just don't understand how
to use the select tool honey you can
only use the select tool if Polaris
highlighted
you have to be their mommies but not
remind them of their mommy any power you
have must be masked under a giggle
oh my God yes
amen sister you can tell him that you've
never seen The Godfather and that you'd
love them to explain it to you can you
start the movie over and just talk
through the whole thing video
essay can
talk to you
oh my god
I'd be mad if this movie wasn't so
accurate
it's fascinating that this corporate
product is like the least corporate
infusion of feminist ideas
I love it it's based AF I am so awkward
and don't feel pretty at all and will
anyone ever like me distract them until
wearing glasses
glasses cover that you're pretty
no like the way they Riff on the genres
of this aesthetic it uses older Cinema
genres to Riff on the aesthetic of the
way we romanticize and idealize stuff
yeah yeah and the yeah interplay between
the Sexes over the years
against each other you make them
question whether they have enough power
over each other
it's like I'm a woman already
welcome
it's what it's like you're coming of age
hi oh Jesus tidied up
oh hey
you've caught me reading
my man I'm ready to be here long-term
distance low commitment casual
girlfriend if you'll still have me oh
nice I could tell you
okay
come on in I'll play the guitar at you
play the guitar at you as it was meant
to be played
oh is this one
[Music]
I'm a little bit of rustier
and I don't know
four hours of Rob Thomas boys
[Laughter]
hilarious
[Music]
Jesus
who are you texting no one let me just
John dang it's a beautiful song that
you're playing you play on their egos
and their Petty jealousies and you turn
them against each other they're gonna
stop I gotta work so well Petty
jealousies would keep the country moving
yes the fragile glue that holds us all
together in the machine
doesn't seem to matter
[Music]
always number two
no one knows how hard I tried
those pecks into it boy all my life been
so polite but I'll sleep alone tonight
I'm just kidding
[Music]
you're in the Ken Zone
storm the beach at Burgundy
gonna be a Mexican
I like how this stays adherent to the
rules of the world yeah
[Applause]
and like the shopping cart formations
pink a post-apocalyptic
[Music]
kick his ass yeah
can Foo
[Music]
yeah the other side
were there real weapons here no no
whoever is like in an 80s musical action
yeah
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is awesome and two that the big
evil plan like culminates in this
musical number like
so childish
[Laughter]
this is the best
[Music]
Yo he's buried in this my name's Kane
so am I
doubt
[Music]
all those in favor of letting Barbie
land be Barbie land
I now go change the real world yes can
we get a reproduction of this outside
I'm so happy
in a world full of Ken's being Allen
these Mojo Dojo Casa houses just get
dreamier weird ADR okay that's because
their dream houses mother
[Music]
with the Mattel logo
don't look at me
oh
are you okay
yeah
I cried too it's actually kind of
amazing I'm a liberated man I know
crying's not weak
true buddy when I found out that
patriarchy wasn't about horses I lost
interest anyway oh you just love horses
I always thought this would be our house
poor guy I'm really sorry I took you for
granted oh I just don't know who I am
without you it's time to find out that's
a good thing I only exist within the
warmth of your gays whoa without it
blood God I can't do flips oh same man
maybe it's Barbie and it's Ken Ken
yes me yes can
is me if you're like an ape me am Ken
Ken
fojo Mojo mink
we were only fighting because we didn't
know who we were
wow
strong maybe psychological political
emotional thanks to the Barbies I too
can now relieve myself of this heavy
existential burden while holding on to
the very real title of CEO
and the pay package that comes with it
please may the Kens have one Supreme
Court Justice oh I can't do that ouch
but maybe a lower circuit court judge
the Kens will have as much power and
influence in Barbie land as women have
in the real world
okay what about ordinary Barbie
that's it it's a terrible idea yeah
that's going to be money oh oh ordinary
Barbie I love it
[Laughter]
she's in love with Ken that is not her
ending
what do you want I don't know I'm make
her own choices I want to figure it out
I don't think I have an ending that was
always the point
I created you so you wouldn't have an
ending
I really feel
like come walk with me
we're going to
the Stream
thank you I am good enough you am
Kenneth humans make things up like
patriarchy and Barbie just to deal with
how uncomfortable it is then you die
fun comfortable I I want to do the
imagining I don't want to be the idea I
always knew that Barbie would surprise
me but I never expected this AI bar
movie don't you control me you're a
Barbie dog control you any more than I
could control my own daughter I named
you after her Barbara
is she really the Creator she's a good
actress I know I was just like she used
to make an appearances
huh
I used to flow
now take your first breath like
Pinocchio samachus Pinocchio
[Music]
and so much experience they grab home
movies from other different casts or did
people send these in from all over the
world yes
yes
she made the choice yeah and the answer
or was it an illusion
the soft part of the Matrix
you got this I'm really proud of you
that's a political statement that's
appropriation
[Music]
the sandals name oh um Handler comma
Barbara
Barbara Handler I'm here to see my
gynecologist
one woman's anatomical completion
wow oh and they even got the aqua remix
nice credits
oh Emerald fennel is Midge okay yeah
yeah
are these real uh
at the real Allen Allen he's Ken's buddy
Helen Mirren was the narrator did not
pick up on that oh yeah yeah
Ruth Handler yeah I don't know uh Barbie
history guys
so
wow that pooping dog was there were some
very peculiar toys out there sugars
daddy God
I remember mermaid Barbie and your
Barbie world in there
that's great can't wait to talk about it
no yeah that was next level all right
kick us off John well uh and during the
the little break there I looked it up
and uh the real Ruth Handler died in
2002 so that was not Ruth okay
um but that was that was quite an
experience that like it's been you know
making these waves in the world and you
come into a movie like this and you're
like okay you know I don't know really
what to expect exactly aside from the
trailer in terms of specifics but you
know how is this going to deliver what
kind of conversation is it going to have
after all this buzz and this was a
really wonderfully kind of mad cap but
also yeah emotional and
thought-provoking experience in a way
that you know really pulled me up in its
own ride I think from the outside you
know you see and you go like oh there's
stuff that looks like The Lego Movie and
things that are gonna comment on you
know like purpose and existentiality if
that's a word
um but it does so in a very different
way coming from what feels like a very
different place and maybe a bit of a
more challenging place than simply
innocence like it deals with that but I
feel like yeah there's so many layers
from you know just the personal to the
political to the existential the
philosophical all that stuff um so yeah
this was another kind of recent movie
experience I can think of that's like oh
yeah this is kind of like so many of the
things that Cinema can be and also it's
having a very interesting and I think
well uh conceived conversation through
all these you know Fantastical silly and
humorous elements and whatnot
um so I mean yeah I was I was quite
gripped and disconcerted all at the same
time I guess I would say
yeah uh the the movie has
brilliant I think it's a genius film uh
I'm surprised by it because it's like
yeah any although the conversation about
like it made a billion dollars and it's
the biggest movie of the year you know
and overtaken Mario it's overtaken
everything
and and
I I did I definitely I avoided a reviews
I avoided everything on it because I
just didn't want to get any opinions
kind of influencing my own I wanted this
to be fresh I had no idea about this
Descent of Ken
I thought was great
because the movie's very accessible and
it's like while I I bet there's a lot of
deeper I mean yeah there's a lot of
things in here that are are deeper and
more subtle and I'm sure there's things
that probably flew over my head this
first time watching it I'm sure there's
probably a lot of things just a guy that
I've I probably just can't truly
comprehend or understand right
yet there's yet there's so much in here
with this messaging that is very direct
like you could you could weirdly see how
this is a very mature adult film yet you
could also see how it's one that a
family can also at the same time weirdly
watch even though like a PG-13 it's like
a PG-13 kind of family film yeah because
there there's some subjects that are
like okay yeah that's way too young
um but you know I like
I don't want to speak for like the right
attainable ages for like a little girl
the right age that is a parent's
decision of when to show this for a
child right I can see how it is very
educational and informative at the same
time because there there's a lot of
things that are very overt there's a lot
of things that like a lot of this is
very direct they're just flat out saying
it and while I know there's been parts
of the internet that have been very much
up in arms about it and then like you
know I've seen like certain titles of
like it hates men or whatever
um
I I didn't get that impression uh at all
I I really did it I think that this
movie has a very brilliant commentary
and I think the reason why it still
clicks so much with with a worldwide
audience why even though it is like the
woke us of the woke the kind of film it
is you know of what we say is woke now
you know yeah of what we Define as that
is is because that's the movie the
movie's about that it's not trying to be
subtle in that it is
it's like front and center with this
film in all aspects that's dialogue it's
every every bit of this film is all
about that and I I think it's when a
movie is trying to like
mask it in a way or or try to be like
they're in subtle hints or whatever nah
this movie is is embracing it from
beginning to end and I feel like that's
why it clicks so well because it has
this rewatch capability and so much
Nuance that you could pick up on because
it's dealing with all kinds of things
you know uh obviously self-acceptance
The Power of Choice uh the patriarchy of
How It's been harmful to woman how it's
also been harmful to men uh
self-reflection gender stereotypes it's
so many different things that it's just
like it interweaving throughout uh
through the reflection like through the
Brilliance of doing this for like a
Barbie adaptation because the first like
half hour
you know because of the hype surrounding
it
I was here going like I'm enjoying this
this is fun uh why is this the billion
dollar phenomenon that it is yeah and
then it then I I want to say it was
around the pudding in the Box moment
that really started to to do a massive
change in my Noggin on it and then also
the hint at what they were doing with
Ken that he's getting exposed to the
patriarchy and the the juxtaposition of
seeing the the reality of how the Barbie
land is this is the is the upside down
world of the real world of you know like
women here are are the dominance that
they have they have the power went on
and then her watching how the mirroring
effect is happening
I thought was just so genius and so
unexpected because even
not knowing at all what they were gonna
do with the Barbie and Ken relationship
not having any clue prior I was
definitely under the impression that it
was still going to be a romantic comedy
yeah I thought that's what we were
getting into I still thought it was
gonna be a romance so I thought the
direction that it took was so surprising
and I I love how it prayed on the um
of how the insecurity of men can often
form into something that is violent and
dangerous totally you know 100 and it's
it's true though it's very very true
yeah but they also make fun of like the
modern day man like he has a line in
there I'm like what does he say like I'm
a liberal man I'm a liberated man I'm
okay with crying you know yeah yeah
that's not a sign of weakness yeah they
make fun of that and that is it that is
a modern part of our progression too and
um I I thought that the because because
at the end of the day it's that while
this movie has so much messaging
throughout as just a film it's a very
entertaining one it's like that's the
that's the thing is like there's some
movies out there where I can walk away
and be like no I I get it I just didn't
like the experience sure you know
because some films are all about its
meaning and not really about what about
the enjoyment Factor like was I invested
in the characters did I enjoy the plot
you know and and this is one of those
movies where I thought they did it all I
thought that it had all its deeper
meanings it had its great messaging it
had it's it's genius infused commentary
but at the same time it still had
characters I was very much endeared to I
loved every second Barbie and Ken were
on screen you know Ryan Gosling and
Margot Robbie specifically obviously uh
when they were on screen I liked America
ferreira's character a lot
um I I thought the plot was very
engaging the visuals were extremely
Dynamic the music was exceptional uh the
the direction in cinematography was
awesome so as it's just a film it's a
it's a very engaging one and then it's
got stuff where it's like the messaging
is very on the nose but it's kind of the
point and then it's it's got stuff where
it's it's deeper than you might expect
and then these like little nuggets of
lines and I'm like wow that line is a
bar right there that line hits home so
yeah man I loved it I thought it was I
thought it was great my only real things
that I didn't quite care for
um
there was something about the Will
Ferrell stuff that I didn't love
I don't know what it was it seemed like
that maybe could have used maybe an
extra beat button or some kind of
I I don't know it
there's something about them that feels
almost tangential and what really
matters is what's going on in Barbie
land between the Barbies and the cans
and that's essentially the reality that
we're mostly subject to and by the end
they're like
I thought they were gonna try and I
don't know I thought they would be
perturbed that things were going back to
normal and that they would try and push
the kingdom you know uh agendum further
or something like that and I mean like I
thought they had a sharp you know a
sharp bit at the end with her pitching
normal person Barbie and then him going
like that's a terrible idea oh wait it's
gonna sell fine which is a nice
commentary on corporate wokeness but um
but yeah I don't know there was
something about those characters that
seemed like they were the most cartoony
and the most like it's a bit out of
everything in the movie and all the fake
neon characters were the most alive and
engaging and yeah I mean it does feel
just kind of like a different Riff on
Lord Business in a way I felt uh I guess
I felt the least
I was like I know the ideas did not be
inventive about them
um
I think it lacked at a movie filled with
creativity and cleverness it was the one
part that was lacking in it for me it
went about is
the execution of them was about as what
I expected when I saw the trailer yeah
where everything else yeah everything
else kind of surprised me yeah where
they were I'm like I feel like I've seen
this portrayal of CEO dumb guys before
who
um you're just like dumb yes men yeah
yeah yeah so that was the only part of
it that that was that didn't exactly
quite uh click for me and it is a bit of
like a a cameo Galore Fest where they
didn't really utilize some people like
there's like there's no real point in
using John Cena
I mean I think it's one of those things
where you're at a point where so many
people are are it's got such a stacked
Ensemble that it's like ah why not you
know this person wants to come by throw
them in but yeah I mean you know you
expect maybe some kind of additional
bits with them maybe they're a lot of I
would expect like maybe there are a lot
of deleted scenes and things like that
too just with like fun stuff that we
couldn't include for pacing or whatever
yeah um but yeah no like this this to me
had that quintessential movie Magic
quality where it is talking to you and
it does have a perspective and it's also
the culmination of so much physical and
intellectual Artistry and thought and
Poise and it used everything I know as
an outsider as a person who never played
with Barbie it used everything I know
about that uh and then multiplied it by
and I think took it uh interesting cues
from just the idea again of playing as a
kid and what that means and why and kind
of likening that to what adults are
experiencing because you know in in ways
you're still looking to this thing for
Comfort you're still projecting onto it
you're still in some ways taking
inspiration from it and it's one of the
earliest ways we learn some of these
interactions in some of the earliest
ways that as kids we can you know unlock
what's really going on inside yeah and
then you know passing those things off
and giving them away Through The Eyes of
the daughter you know is as you come of
age and then having Barbie come of age
uh I don't know yeah it made for like a
fascinating blame even though you do
spend so much time in this fantasy world
it made for a fascinating blend of human
themed like it's obviously overt in
terms of like the socio-political
conversation that it's having but it's
also really encompassing of just the
again stress and chaos and confusion of
being alive and the ways in which we
expand and contract just our
vulnerability and who we are truly as
people as we navigate this world that is
set up in a way that feels so shiny and
official and you know regimented and yet
truly at the end of the day is not and
never will be and so I think it it
encompassed just that all around chaos
and and existential uh you know angst of
being alive and trying to figure out why
you're feeling all the things that
you're feeling and I love the alley-oop
expecting like oh it's gonna be Amer
America Ferreira it was it's her doll or
something like that and then you know
she's a little girl grown up I thought
having the mother-daughter story and
having those two perspectives uh
represented as well and you see kind of
the start of you know the difficulty
that coming of age can be through that
daughter that also is going on through
Barbie but also the wistful memory of
what has been and what could have been
through the mom and things like that and
the things that you know maybe you
down so that you could appear more
together or with it and two then just
commenting on like well what's Barbie's
role in our actual world and you know
what is the importance maybe or the
detriment maybe of a toy that is pitched
one or another way and uh and that
matches really well with the subject of
the movie itself so it's I think this is
one of those really nice kind of Nexus
point films where what it's doing makes
a lot of sense but it also matches the
subject in the narrative as well as the
subject outside of the narrative and
it's all gleefully mad cap and it has
just the right right amount of like
creeping Terror at certain points or
just this sense that like things are off
or Sinister and yeah that whole thing
with getting the box and let us tie you
down you know and pose you the exact way
we want to and the back and forth
between you know a problematic figure
like a Barbie where so much of the
history is like men making money but
also pretending or at least being
behooved because it makes money to
encourage you know women and girls too
blah blah blah yeah I like the Barbie
Arc a lot because what she's learning to
be human uh in a way that's about
embracing imperfection and embracing the
the the pain and the Sorrows that come
with being human and embracing the
anxieties but also what the power and
the reward and catharsis is of
overcoming and the the true development
of strength that comes from fighting for
something and then coming out on on top
but also just dealing with
any kind of really it just comes down to
just the Embrace of experience you know
like that's why I loved how
nothing really seemed like her learning
to be human came down to anything that
was about materialistic you know like
there was a good amount of emphasis on
the the relief of
of crying and how the expression of
Tears is actually something that can be
very rewarding and and feel very good
yeah everything about it was just about
human experience and embracing that uh
even for Ken you know like it was cool
how they had two very different Journeys
one that was very reflective of males
and the other reflective of women and
yet they still landed on the same spot
which is we have to just know who we are
yeah you know and and that should be the
thing that comes first and and foremost
and understanding individualism as well
is so important because so much of this
is about
being influenced by what Society Norms
are like you see that with Ken you know
because he's just a lost boy you know
yeah and I I loved that they they
managed to tell two very different
stories with them but also like it's
stemming from how it stems from perfect
Barbie as we all know the perfect doll
and then yeah and then there's cats yeah
yeah Ken who was just created for party
you know yeah and it turns a
compassionate eye toward that stuff and
I think that's where I can yeah you hear
all these people being like Oh the movie
hates men and Ken is they made him such
a you know lame character or a character
that we're supposed to laugh at who
isn't really cool but like history of
Barbie and Ken actually not being that
cool aside I think they did it nicely to
yeah portray him as this very insecure
and very sort of petty guy but look at
what is beneath that and what a and
the fact and the fact that I think like
people get offended by that like Get
over yourself yeah exactly right and
there are people like this and
oftentimes especially like alpha males
who are you know preaching the the word
of men's rights and things like that are
often fixated on women even still and
they're often just Pawns in a greater
again machine that is yeah is kind of
giving you various benefits kind of off
the bat but at the same time is not
actually necessarily empowering you or
giving you you know the things you need
to just yet live your most fulfilled
life for real and there's so many
distractions I feel like yeah like in
the way Society works right now there
are so many ways men can fall into these
toxic traps and become you know the
kingdom that we see here because yeah
there's a lot of pent-up emotion and
this feeling of yeah I mean even though
it's very different in the ways men and
women experience it and and what power
that allots in society there's still
this sense of I'm supposed to be
extraordinary and unique and yet I'm
just one of like a bunch of their
millions of me there are millions of
people everywhere what is my purpose
what do I do and yeah it was obviously
changed a good amount and continues to
in terms of what we're able to
acknowledge and express but for so long
it has been that thing of you know you
just have it together and you keep that
stiff upper lift and you and you and you
you lead with your strong masculine
qualities and you're fine and that's
what life is for and it's not you know
it's it's another box you know it's
another pose that they're trying to make
and two I mean even though uh it's that
same kind of thing it's like you're not
just defined by your job and even though
there's a bunch of different Kens with a
bunch of different jobs you're just you
at the end of the day and yeah it's only
one part I guess it's just all kind of
Testament to how like life is so many
things and you cannot just be one and it
will never just always be the same and
there is no kind of blissful uh you know
Plato's perfect heaven where things just
continue on in you know Perfection and
you're always sated and content and
happy
um and yeah like it's very different the
way men experience life in society but I
think a lot of that on both sides is
encompassed here and it's also very of
the now while being kind of Timeless
within those themes well and I think too
uh Mattel is genius for green lighting
this for now yeah because
uh it's also a fantastic advertisement
for Barbie
on the darkest level it is as much as
this is about like it's it's not it it
is it is a com one of the many
commentaries is about is of course How
uh of the many things is also talking
about corporations and all that and at
the same time and like how corporations
have negatively affected us is with with
like the image of the standards of
Barbie and whatever
it is still a brilliant advertisement to
get more Barbie and Ken and get the
Margot Robbie stereotypical barf and
like the movie goes down that path with
like oh we're selling the the damaged
woman Barbie brand right now you know
yeah and I'm like but I feel like if
they sold it in real life people would
buy it especially the heels of this
movie especially deals of a billion
dollar hit like I have a I have a Ken
Barbie doll right now yes you do like
I'm jealous the thing is it's also like
wow what a what a what a kind of a a
sinistered plan of like hey it's still
it's a little great attitude we can
still sell this you know yeah yeah
one that's the thing it's even kind of
encompassed in the film because it's one
of those things where it's like if we
didn't know that so many of the boxes
that we're checking are already gonna
net us a profit you know then we
probably wouldn't be on board for all
the things you want to say but because
it's probably gonna make maybe we don't
know it's gonna make a billion so it's
probably going to make a good amount of
money given all of our resources yeah
say whatever you want yeah we'll only
get involved when we think it's gonna
hurt the bottom line and it's yeah it's
a bit of a unicorn because we live in a
time where there is so much kind of
trite stiff or awkward uh incorporation
of
hate what the conversations turn the
word woke into so I'm just going to say
like enlightened principles are often
pitched in these movies and Blockbusters
that is the wokest thing you could have
ever said John just trying to be basic
just trying to be as based as I can be
but you know we get a lot of really
trite and kind of eye roll worthy uh uh
you know lip service to equality and
various things in our media and this is
not doing that this is bothering to go
the full depth and so while this is
literally a giant commercial product uh
at the same time yeah it is kind of
allowed to be all that it can be and
that's a special thing and I you know am
ever fascinated by how these things slip
through in the form that they do and
then it often does just come down to it
will make money so it's fine say
whatever you want yeah
um but it really does you know speak
wider than you would expect and and as
you know I expected something good
something with some intelligence
something with some subtext but you know
this was kind of always exploring that
stuff it never took a break really just
to be fun past a certain point once
you're established with everything and
so yeah it's like you can just enjoy it
on that level if you want to but you can
enjoy it for so many others as well and
I think too the reason it has made as
much as as it has is because it is
speaking universally even though
definitely the Battle of the Sexes is so
embraced by the plot and well ingrained
in the imagery and the happenings of the
movie and all that stuff you know it
does appeal like Barbie's journey is
universal as well in some ways maybe not
as much but Ken's is two and especially
it's like Barbie having the crisis of
like I can be kind of anything and this
is still not solving everything and can
coming into our world and being like
this is kind of the one thing that we're
supposed to do you know it all kind of
leads to a mess at the end and uh yeah
it's wonderfully Lifey and also like
yeah it seems like they really pulled
nope punches with this script at all or
didn't think franchise which is
fascinating too when you think Mattel
was wise enough to approve all this
and now they want to make 16 movies
based on all their other toys so like
what did they understand this to begin
with you know there are various kind of
capitalist hellscape questions to ask
yourself but in this moment this is yeah
no I doubt that the any any future
Mattel movie is going to be as good as
this no no no no no this is this is way
too like Greta Gerwig and and Noah
bombach's voice Greta go rig especially
though like her voice is is one of the
main stars of this movie oh yeah totally
um so yeah congratulations to everyone
involved I'm Barbie uh like I think all
the success and praise as well well
deserved oh this is a very unique
experience and for of finally getting a
live action adaptation of Barbie being
brought to life uh this is the last
thing I think anyone really expected
because it is weird it is strange it's
odd it's Fantastical it's a little bit
horror it's a little bit sci-fi but it's
great I thought it was a fantastic film
and meta without being obnoxious
references without being obnoxious yeah
yeah yeah
alrighty guys well what did you think of
Barbie did you love it leave your
thoughts down below and hey before we go
let's end this with a patron of the day
shout out
I'm on Saturday Nisa Oliva
John if she was a Barbie doll what would
you do ah I wanna push you around well
how will well how will Anisa come over
to come come back to California so we
can Beach all right that's what we need
to do is we need to go Beach and then
I'll sing it to you for four straight
hours and if you check yourself I am
gonna cry sadly she would love that
don't check your phone because we're
meant to be it's on the box Anissa and
John
sold separately Batteries Not Included
intended for ages five to nine
you got a little more on you come on I
love you Anisa you should stay pledged
so that we can well someday let all the
pledge money goes to I didn't want to
tell you this before but I'm building
your Malibu Dream Castle all right here
in the great state of Los Angeles land
is dirt cheap and uh it's being erected
as we speak it's got a swirly uh Pool
slide it's got your pink Corvette it's
got uh the dog that poops candies I hope
uh that's there it's all there and every
day we'll have a party and you'll be
president and I will uh you know just
hang out on the beach all day and wait
for you
and wait and wait for you and wait for
you some more and then when you get
there my life will have meaning again
and we can have fun on the beach and
I'll sing you a song that goes like this
I wanna push you around
I wanna push you down well I'm going to
no Harmony it's okay it's all right I
was thinking about other stuff it's my
only it's that's it's that's my song all
right you get your own song that you can
sing to Olivia but Anissa and I we're
gonna go live in the Malibu dream house
together
videos
it's done now right that's never done no
it's
it was done a couple of minutes ago I'm
going to the real world
[Music]